MBN UP AGAINST IN TH
IT IS TRUL TO HAND COMT.E RUSSI
OSN BAMUS
CENTER -EP I THIS IS
SE, ARE SUSTAINING HEAVY LOSSES.
THEY ARE RECORDING MORAN
HUEAURS.
WESTS SAY TH
ARE RU MAN
POWER AND LIKELY HAVST
RU MINISTRY.UBS AND GYMS
NEWRE PROMPTI
CALL ON TO STONDEM LAMBS TO SLA.
E RUSSIAN WOMEN, THEY
Y R LOD ESFO JTR
VIF CONSISTEN W
DOES PUTIN, ETSK ANYHTF TS AT T?
>> I WOULD THIREPORTS FROM T UK
WE KNOW YOU
MENTIONED THE WAGNER GROUP.
50,000 SOLDIERS, 40,000
OF THEM ARE  THAPRISON
AND TH DRIVE LAS
YEAR MAY HAVE LLED IAN EQUAL AM
BAD SITUATION, AND C
WHAT THEY'RE DOING WITH G EM IN
REALLY IMMORAL,UCH TRNI
ANE POIN
FP WITH AT'S HAPPENING HERE,AV
YOUNG  MEAGRINDELL UKRE OBTAINE
RUTAINED BY AN
THNO AT UGE WE SAWORPSESED WITH
THEIR TSANAT LKIS,G THIS IN INTN
LDS INCRED
NEND PRECISE?
>>IL FIELDVER
PARTICULAR.
LOGSCORD O ON THBATTEL EE ROFIVJ
COMMANRS
TROOPS, IF YOU DON'T ADVANCE
WHEN YOU COME
BACK.
UKIAFOR COUNTRY, FOR THEIR
WINNING.WHAT'SPE TO THIS
GENERATION OF RUSSIAN ME  HORRI
IT'SNL GET WORSE
BECAAT SOME POINT, THE
UKRAINIANS ARE GOING
E IN
APRIL OR MAY, AN'SO
PUSH THE A POINT
CRORE N FROMEIR UNTRY.
>> THIS IS HAPPENINGS WITHIN
CIOBVIOUSLNOT USING THE WORD
T THE INSTITUTE OF
Y  T
S LIKELY SEIZING THE
E ANWAGNER FORCEL THLEADER O
KREMLIN.
THEY SAYURPOSELY
TRYING TO GEORCEKILLED OFF
TRYING US
HAPPIN WELL, ON THE ONE ND IBUT
RP
PREGOSIAN HAS MADE AN ENEMY OF
MANY, VITIQUE AL
E CHAIN OF COMMAND
WIY FORMER CS SEARCHING FOR INFN
THLIN ANO WO
HIWAY CL T
WHAT'S INTERNG, TOO,
PREGOSIAN FROM THE BATTLEFIE SAI
KREMLIN AND THE KRN T
CURIOUS WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
COUNTRY.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE YOUNG BOYS.
UNFORTATELY IT SEEMSS
INE ETHNIC MINORITIES,
MOSCOW OR
AROU M
REHEC MINORITIES
MOSCOW, THE THREAT OF NUCLEAR C
WITH CHINA.
AND FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMPOWA.
HEUSNG.
I WANTED TO PLAYT
>>G BEFORE YODAY, I
AM ONLNDIDATE WHO CAN
MAKE THIS PROMIS--L
PRT WORLD WA
OIORLD WAR III. YOU KRV HIM AS
PRESIDENT.
WHAT?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK WE'REG T.
GOING TO HAVE A FINE SLATEF IN
MI
PRIMARY  TSI AND I THINK MANY
OF THEM ARABLE,  ARGUEE NEEDW GN